Can we pray kaza namaz kaza salah at the
time of any other namaz salah for
example I had left the fudar prayer due
to oversleep maybe you didn't get up in
the morning so can I pray kaz salah of
fudar at the time of
zohara please
clarify if you have missed any of your f
salah whether it be fajar salah or z
salah or assur
Or Isha the ruling is that a Muslim
cannot miss the salah
voluntarily if involuntary for example
you did not get up for the fud salah you
kept the alarm and you didn't get
up then Allah will forgive you but the
moment you realize that you have to pray
immediately for example you did not get
up for fud salah and you wake up after
the sun has risen the sun rises at 7:00
you wake up at 9:00 the moment you get
up you should pray immediately. You
cannot say I will wait till Zohar salah
is there. Yes, if you sleep and don't
get up after sunrise and get up at the
time of Zor salah then no problem. You
pray the fajar salah first then pray the
zor salah. You cannot wait. But if you
keep on sleeping and you get up at zar
time then what you have to do? You have
to pray fudar salah first then pray zar
salah. Always as far as the far salah
are concerned you should pray in order.
You cannot pray first z and then fud. No
if you have missed your fud salah first
you have to pray fud salah and then pray
the zor salah then assur. But you cannot
say I will pay my fud. If you missed a
fud salah and the zor salah time has
come. You pray a zor salah prays and
then you pray a fud at the time of m.
This is wrong. You have to pray in the
same order. The sunnah salah if you do
kazada sunada etc in a different order
it's permitted but as far as the far
salah is concerned you should read your
salah in order so if you missed your faj
salah and you get up at zor time see to
it that before you join the zohar jama
you pray a faj salah important but if
you're unable to pray before the z salah
and the z jama starts then you pray fud
at the time of zor you can join the jama
and pray. While the Imam is praying
salah, you pray two raat and sit down in
the second. Let the Imam complete the
fourth rakat. When he does salam, you do
a salam. So that you pray a faj salah
first and then you pray salah. You have
to maintain the order in the far salah.
But if you miss any of the far salah
because
of unavoidable circumstances like you're
sleeping or you forget, Allah will
forgive you. You pray as soon as you
realize but voluntary leave you cannot
miss okay now I'm going shopping I know
I have to pray my I will miss my and
join together with m it is a major sin
in Islam voluntarily purposely knowing
missing any of the far salah is a major
sin it is the fourth major sin
accord after shik after murder after
black magic the fourth major sin
according to Imamadhabi is not offering
your first salah
So voluntary leaving because of some
other reason it's not permitted. If you
oversleep, if you forget or if is the
danger of life and death then if your
house is on fire during m time and then
you are putting off the fire and then if
you miss it's okay but generally for
shopping or for other reason you cannot
miss any of your far salah. Hope that
answers the question.